The joe rogan experience,
we just never stopped coming at you.
Excellent striking technique.
Take a tremendous,
my whole thing with it though is as soon as you test positive once I'd take you
out of the greatest PR.
It's just against the rules.
I'm not even against steroids,
like take steroids,
you know,
like if it's your endocrinologist tells you to take steroids,
go fucking do it.
Good.
Good for you.
But in our sport,
unfortunately it's against the rules.
So there's only a certain amount of people doing it.
So if you're doing it,
you're cheating.
Right.
And,
but do you think John was taking steroids?
I don't know,
but I don't think he was,
but to be honest,
it doesn't matter to me.
I mean,
you know,
I've said this for a long time.
I think it should be a lifetime ban.
First offense period.
Yeah.
And there's going to be martyrs.
There would be guys like,
I don't think 10 means was taking steroids.
He certainly did not look like it did.
He wasn't,
Oh really?
I didn't know what that far,
okay.
Found the supplement that he was taken.
There was a totally legal supplement.
You get a bunch of shit big companies or these uh,
companies rather than get it from China and they,
they have these bins and like we had a problem with that with the Alpha brain
when we first had,
not steroids but vitamins that were in Alpha brain that weren't supposed to win
to be there.
We have all our stuff independently tested and when we had it independently
tested,
it turns out that the mixers then when they were putting all the different
ingredients and they will be putting in these vats and they had used these vats
for other shit and had a completely cleaned it out.
This is a problem with companies that sell steroids and also sell things like
creating like this is the,
this is the big story about John Jones.
This is the big rumor.
This is what they're,
what they think is that he was doing coke that had creatine in it.
It was cut with creating that creatine probably had trace elements of steroids.
The reason why that makes sense is because he tested negative right before that
test and then tested positive and then tested negative again a short time after
that.
This is a steroid that takes several months to get out of your system,
but it got out of his system very quickly,
which would indicate it was a very,
very small trace amount,
not an amount that you would take if you were actually using it to try to,
you know,
to get a performance enhancing benefit.
That's what I,
I book.
It makes sense to me.
And so it makes sense.
Nitsky too.
It's fair enough.
And I,
I'm certainly there's cases,
so under in my world where,
okay,
first offense,
lifetime ban,
I take a lot of guys would be a lot more careful with things like hat for one.
And I think,
uh,
you know,
there'll be a due process.
So,
you know,
say he proved that or like 10 meetings,
prove it,
you know,
he comes right back.
Right.
Um,
and I also think unfortunately there would be people that would probably,
uh,
you have no bad intention and would,
have the,
you know,
end up testing positive and having a lifetime ban and there'll be martyrs
basically.
Champ.
I can't sign off on martyrs,
man.
Too many too to have dreams,
you know,
for sure.
What about
you?
Like what if you accidentally took some creatine and some bullshit?
Personally,
I'm extremely diligent.
I do my,
I do my due diligence,
man.
I got,
I worked with muscle farm for years now and like I know that and they have great
stuff.
Yeah.
They may have based stuff.
I know that it's good stuff.
I,
that's my primary supplement source.
I mean,
I,
I'm,
I don't go do coke.
You know what I mean?
Like if you do those things and something bad happens to you,
that's your fault.
You know what I mean?
If,
if,
if for instance,
he was doing coke and,
uh,
he,
you know,
not knock on John Jones either.
I mean,
I'm not living his life.
I mean it's,
he's in a difficult situation as a young kid,
uh,
you know,
with God,
I mean,
I can only imagine the amount of people approaching him for crazy things and
trying to talk him into all this.
And so I have some sympathy for his situation.
But,
you know,
you make the choice,
you have to pay the consequences for the choice.
I agree that you should pay the con the choice,
the consequences for the choice.
I just don't agree that the price should be so high.
You know,
like,
like when you think about a guy like Anderson Silva,
Anderson Silva just tested positive again.
Again.
Do you think that that takes him out of the consideration for the greatest wall
tie?
In my mind,
100%.
See,
I even doing it because he's old.
He's doing it because he's 40.
So we,
again,
we can feel whatever
feel right.
I mean,
I feel like he probably wasn't doing it the whole time,
but he might've been.
Yeah,
but do I?
No.
Hell No.
You ever see his trainer?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I,
Eric Silva when I fought him.
You know his trader looks ridiculous.
He's set like 70 years old.
He's just flunking.
Yeah,
it looks like the hall.
He's like 5% body fat at 60 years old.
Like I sent a picture to the guy to Dana and I go,
this is Anderson's trainer,
lol.
And Dana sends you back.
Holy Shit.
Are you serious?
Like oh yeah,
that's his trainer.
Oh fucking guys.
So Jack Dana's certainly seen him around to,
you have so straight it.
Lots of guys.
Is that,
that's just not,
that's a different guy,
man.
He's younger.
He's right there in your
book to the picture.
To the left is left is the one.
Yeah,
that's the picture.
I said Dana,
he's so,
I mean it's fucking abs stick out like Blegh biceps.
Each one of his abs looks like a a bodybuilder's Bicep,
which is glued to it.
That's great.
Listen,
there's like you can get big at 60 you could be pretty built at 60 you can't be
that bill.
It's not positive.
It's like 0.01% of the population that can do that.
Maybe they all live in Africa.
Yeah.
They're out there.
I'll have like super genes,
you know,
they're all like Francis and condos,
relatives.
So few people that are built like that.
Good man.
Not at that age.
You know,
at that age,
you know,
the body starts to diminish.
There's just no if,
ands,
or buts about it.
Do you know that he's at old for sure.
Yeah.
That guy's old.
Yeah,
he's in his sixties it's funny.
He's a,
I think he's an ex jam,
right?
Is that it?
[inaudible] I know he trained Eric Silva who was a GM.
He was in his corner and I was like,
I'm glad I'm fighting a little guy.
Not Him.
Nope.
Change boy.
You want to talk about a post Usada guy?
Like he's,
he's one of him.
And Vito Vito,
obviously it was a testosterone replacement therapy,
but I think Johnny Hendricks was probably the most obvious.
Right.
Formance wise for sure.
You got to wonder about Hendrix,
like how much of it was burnout,
how much of it was possibly he was taking something?
You gotta say it possibly because he never tested positive for anything.
But absolutely.
Yeah.
But Dude,
he was launching people across.
I was the last fight before you saw the,
when I fought him,
you know,
I felt a strength.
I've seen his body.
I mean,
I felt it firsthand is a completely different world.
Completely different compared to now.
It doesn't look the same.
He doesn't fight the same.
Certainly part,
part of that has to be motivation to,
I mean,
he's just,
there's no way he,
he's under the same,
uh,
mental,
aspiration that he had before.
He's just,
he just looks at it differently.
It could be also because his hormones are all fucked up.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's a big speculation.
If he was on something and then he's off his hormones crash,
there's no way they can't.
That's just hand that and that affects your mind.
Right.
100%.
I'm never take it,
but I mean,
I see people that go on and off of it and they're like depressed and look at the
tour.
Remember when [inaudible] came back?
I mean there's so many pictures of detour when he fought like Michael Bisping
and then you see V tour after Usada and he just,
he's got that old man bod and he goes in there and his body's kind of like loose
and it just,
it's your body's not producing hormones anymore if he takes on that shit.
When he was 19 man,
well yeah I guess.
Yeah,
Randy and he was 240 pounds and his neck started up here.
His neck started about two inches above his ears and just went down straight to
his shoulder.
He's so fast.
Ridiculously fast.
Especially when he fought tank five ridiculously fast.
Yeah.
Cause I would have for us any,
as I say,
like if you slow down when you stopped taking that stuff,
like if your muscles actually uh,
you know,
your fast twitch muscles go away or something like that,
body crashes right.
When you're that jacked up on steroids,
your whole body,
first of all,
your,
your balls are just like on vacation.
I mean,
I know you get stronger,
but what about,
you know,
speed though.
That's a different thing.
I said,
a lot of speed is from a neurological,
right?
It's a lot of,
uh,
you know,
the nervous system.
So I wonder,
you know,
about the effects.
I'm like,
well,
I don't know.
Did you see the study?
Uh,
Andy Galpin just came out with which one?
He just posted it the other day about a epigenetic memory of muscles.
Yes.
So this is,
I think,
a big problem with the steroids because I say I do steroids when I'm 19.
Now my muscles get jacked and now my muscles remember how to get that jacked
again.
Um,
even though I'm off steroids for 10 years and then I come back at 30 and,
and Redo it.
Yeah,
that's a very good point.
That's a very good point.
And a very real point.
Yeah.
You body has muscle memory and especially if you do it when you're young and
then your body has an adequate amount of time to rebuild and you start
developing a natural hormone level that also increases your tendon strength.
It increases,
it increases ligament strength.
I mean,
it just,
your body changes it,
it changes the density of your muscles or your bones.
It just does.
There's a lot of bet.
I mean,
and then there's another argument for women and women that have taken steroids.
It's even more intense argument because you're putting supernatural levels of
testosterone in a woman's body.
They develop all this new muscle tissue that never would have been there without
it,
and a certain amount of that sticks around.
And do you know,
you might not even ever been able to develop that kind of strength without it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's what,
that was the first thing I thought of when I seen that study.
Yeah.
And that was where I was,
I,
you know,
there's,
there's always a lot more to it than meets the eye.
Okay.